what does she just want to be a princess
i guess she wants to be president she
was a friend she wants to run for
president oh she does
she does she has aspirations of
presidential yeah yeah
you know she's going to be she's by the
time she gets to the point where she
could
aoc will already have taken the spot
that she's after
i really think aoc is going to work i'm
really excited for an aoc presidency
though
why is that oh yeah it's going to be
like it's going to be like uh
being in a circus you know there's going
to be like trapeze there's going to be
crown
like the news is going to be crazy it's
going to be great and they're going to
be telling you how great she's doing is
you know things are on fire yeah she's
going to be standing there with a smile
on her face people behind her are like
screaming and they're just like
please disperse nothing to see here
it'll really end up being like the
the hunger games really where like you
know the the people that are in
district one in in dc in the area are
doing very very well and they're
vomiting so they can
can keep gorging themselves you know
what i love the rest of the country is
going to be
falling yeah what people understand is
like i don't know if you heard the quote
from greta tunberg
where she was like we don't want to wait
till 20 30. she's like we don't want to
wait till 2050 or 2030
or not even you know 2021 we want it now
we want to end these investments and
subsidies
it's like yeah right 20 million people
will die overnight
yeah because like we transport food into
areas that have no food
could you imagine if they got rid of
fossil fuels like the antarctic
antarctic
researchers would just die just like
instantly they would just die if only
like the ghost of christmas future could
come
and grab all the socialists and be like
if we implemented all of your stuff this
is the future that you get
you know that'd be great just the get
get where's that ghost at christmas
future to
come and show everybody what what the
future would be like if they got what
they wanted
i think it's because um you know going
back to the conversation we were having
about
not you know poor people being kind of
well off with those weird distribution
issues
you've got these people that spent their
whole life
with everything handed to them and
we're at this point now where we're so
well off there's almost no struggle
even when you're poor you got food you
got air conditioning you got clean water
you got a hot bath and that's poverty
level in this country i'm not saying
life is good for them relative to where
it is for the middle class
but relative to people 100 years ago
it's living like kings
and so what happens is what's you know
if you can't clean yourself and if if
you have dirty water you live in the
middle of nowhere drink from a well you
get infections you get parasites
you get sick life is a struggle now
we're at a point where even our
you know lower middle class are living
very very well relatively
and so based on survivability standards
which would be universal not
predicated upon the success of our
country they're kings
and so they grow up with their bare
necessities
almost essentially met everything's
handed to them they go to school they're
told what to do they get a job they go
they you know
finally they go they go through college
high school whatever
they get their degrees and they're told
to do the entire entire time
they have no understanding about about
resource distribution
they've probably never even grown grown
a plant they have no idea where their
food comes from
yeah so they're just like i wake up and
there's food oh
you know what i'm gonna stop right there
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you a
joke this is a really funny ski
sketch where this apartment's all messy
and this guy's girlfriend comes in and
she she wakes up her boyfriend and she's
like you need to clean this mess up and
he goes
wait let me show you something and he
puts the garbage on top of the coffee
table and he goes
now all we have to do is go to sleep and
we wake up it'll be gone
and then she's like are you kidding me
because she's the one who's cleaning all
the
trash that's kind of what it's like yeah
they they just wake up one day they walk
in the cafeteria and there's food
well i don't know where it came from i
would add also unemployment is very
strange i've been on unemployment i
don't know if you guys have ever been
unemployed before but you get
you lose your job you sign up you start
getting a check 500 bucks a week or
whatever
but if you get a job that's going to pay
you 400 bucks a week
you lose your 500 bucks a week so
there's incentivizing you to not
get a job yeah these are the people now
that are out there
they're probably on unemployment because
of covet a lot of people encouraged to
not get a job
it's worse than that when i was on
unemployment
i was a i worked a job that was
essentially sales it was fundraising and
so it was commission based
but that meant that the unemployment i
was eligible for was dramatically lower
than what i actually earned on average
and so when i was talked
on the phone with the woman she said you
know have you looked for work and i said
i have
and i was like i have a question though
because there are jobs i could get but
they pay
so much less than what i used to make
and like i'm getting paid well no no no
stop stop
don't take a job that pays you less stan
unemployment and i was like
why and she said when we get people
who take a job that pays less than their
unemployment they quit the job
they lose the job you need to make sure
you can maintain your standard of living
otherwise you'll be back on unemployment
that's actually a good point if if you
if you have a base requirement if you
have a car payment and a mortgage or a
rent or whatever
and your unemployment's covering it and
you find a job that will pay you but it
pays less than your your necessities
she was basically saying we can't have
that because then you'll be homeless
you'll be in trouble yeah
but that still creates this problem
where it's like okay i'll stand on
employment i won't find it i won't take
the job
and i feel like what do you do i feel
like milton friedman talked about that
kind of stuff
um i'm not super uh well
read on uh on
austrian economics and stuff but that's
something that libertarians do talk
about is
is when you have
government provided safety nets and
stuff if you're if you're making
uh you know if you're making 500 a week
from the government
then you're not going to get a job for
450 or 4
400. a better way to put it is that it
creates a tendency
maybe most people would say i'd rather
work because work is fulfilling
but maybe just enough people get trapped
and then you create a trap where you
grad
you gradually catch more and more people
and it gets worse and worse and worse i
think that's the biggest problem is the
fact that
it becomes a trap where people
you know if you're getting 500 a week uh
to start something on your own that's
actually above
board that you're going to be you know
unless you're doing like a side hustle
that you're not
telling the government about but like if
you're going to start something on your
own
then people get used to making a certain
amount of money so even if you can
cut back and survive on 400
there's not a whole lot of incentive to
do that right you know just to get off
the government handout
so what do you think about ubi universal
basic income uh
there again that's something that that
milton friedman uh had talked about
uh and there is a libertarian argument
if it gets rid of
all other entitlements it's something
that i think that
you know may be worth talking about but
that was yang's position yeah
yeah if and that you know i i didn't
hate on yang at all uh
i liked him i think ubi i'm not a big
fan of it but i thought he has a very
comprehensive policy across the board
i like him except for the fact that he
was a democrat and
it's not and it's not because it's not
because there's anything wrong with
democrats it's because of the official
dnc
right party it's not that he's a
democrat and has the
you know uh would like democrat policies
it's because i believe the dnc
official is corrupt you know i can give
you one simple reason why you don't vote
for democrats
you you can get a moderate democrat to
come out and say i agree with everything
you said
100 and i will put forth bills and i
will agree on all of those things and
guess what
when nancy pelosi says where i'm
teaching trump they go okay
yeah so you're empowering pelosi and
schumer
and you know i look at these moderate
democrats who won in 2018 and the meme
idea like to use is the lord of the
rings you know cast cast into the flames
you've got uh azildur holding the the
one ring and it says orange man
bad and they they promised they would
cast into the fires if you just got them
to mount doom yeah and then once they
were there the moderates yelled cast
into the flames and no
and they walked out and they went to
impeach trump the orange man is bad
it's such an idiotic god it's awful so
uh that that's
that's that's so that's when i was like
you know what you can't vote for him
even if even if you do like i really
liked yang and i really like tulsi and i
i don't agree with everything tulsi has
uh on in terms of her policy positions
yeah or yang either when it comes to ubi
specifically specifically i just thought
yang had like the most comprehensive
list of plans that i've seen in a long
time i'm a big i'm a big 2a supporter
um and that for me is yeah he was they
were both gun control they're both bad
and i've changed i've flipped on that
completely yeah because of the riots
yeah and then
i've always been kind of a pro 2a guy
but the
the fact that there's so many people
that are you know purchasing guns and
i don't know if you've tried to buy ammo
but it's a nightmare oh man it's gone
possible tonight
um and i've taken you know i've got i go
to
i go to classes every single year i'm
one of those guys that's like if
if i talk about guns i'm i try to go
down the four basic firearms safety
rules you know and
and i really advocate people getting out
and training and i
put up video of me training so that way
people see that i'm not just talking
about it which i think there are too
many people that do that like i actually
walking the walk
um and if you could give me a democrat
that would just say you know what
i think that the second amendment means
what it says
and that's something that i'm really not
gonna worry about i'm not i'm not
pro gun control i could look at
democrats completely different
if they you know if there was someone
that was like oh
the second amendment means what it says
but did you ever read the
the original text of the first draft of
the second amendment
um i don't know maybe not
i know that there were multiple drafts
and there were different places that
they put commas and stuff like that so
let me let me see if i can find it so
um i think it's in wikipedia maybe
we can't unite it's a bill of rights i
don't know if i'll be able to find it
actually but there were
17 before we should get those printed up
and put on the wall
the original the original 17. it was
like the 17 articles i don't think i'm
gonna be able to find it in this because
do you wanna google do you wanna search
it no no it's on wikipedia it's a list
but i'll just tell you basically the
original text
specifically said that
a person who was who doesn't want to
join the armed forces still has the
right to bear arms oh really
they got rid of it i think because they
were worried that it would
ban conscription or something like that
but right now one of the big arguments
we see we see from the left is a
well-regulated militia the government's
supposed to regulate it and it's like
that's not what they meant that's not
what that and the original text said
something like this will not be i
don't have the exact language pulled up
but it was something like a person who
refuses military service
you know still retains their right to
bear arms because what they're trying to
make sure of
you know just because someone wasn't
going to be in a militia they can still
have a gun
yeah the the idea that considering the
constitution is a
a document that expressly
gives power to the government and then
the bill of rights
is a list of things specifically
off limits to the federal government if
you take the context
if you look at it from that context
there's no prior restraint
or no prior limitation to what
a person is allowed to own and i hear
some people
arguing that had the dc versus heller
case
created a freedom or something like that
um what's the case the dc versus heller
case is about whether an individual has
a right to own
a gun for personal protection and
the the the court found yes they the
individual does have a protected right
to own a gun for personal protection
and it's it's fairly simple
um the people that are that find
uh an issue with gun control or
find an issue with the second amendment
and that are pro-gun control the way
that they approach it
is that the government has the authority
to
give you rights and your rights
come from your humanity your the
government doesn't have
the ability to give you a right they can
give you an entitlement so if you
the right to health care is actually an
entitlement to the government
paying for your healthcare so the people
yeah not the because
the people have to supply the resources
in the laboratory exactly so
but there's that brings in the argument
of positive versus negative rights and
and i don't think positive rights are
actually rights they're not really right
yeah negative rights are the only rights
that can this is because you've talked
about going out in the woods and you
know you have the right you can say
whatever you want in the woods because
you can say it and no one can stop you
you can build a you can take a a stick
and turn it into a weapon to
you know because no one can stop you but
the actual
having to do something for someone else
is where is the problem so yeah so the
way i usually explain it is
if you want to figure out what your
rights are strip naked and go in the
middle of the woods
yeah anything you can do is your right
to do that's fair you can defend
yourself you can create a weapon you can
scream all you want and you're naked you
can take a dump
um once you start imposing on other
people like taking a dump in their water
you got problems
but uh so there's no there's no doctor
you have a right to health care oh okay
yell the grizzly see if he'll come fix
your wound
it's not gonna happen that was reading
about positive and negative rights and
the easiest way to explain it
is that a negative right to life means
i can't kill you we all have that in
this country
a positive right to life means that if
ian tries to kill you i am obligated to
save you
or if you're dying or injured i'm
obligated to save you i must do
something
that's not a right you have no right to
someone else's
life and i think that's the big
difference between authoritarian and
libertarian
or i shouldn't say it's one of the i
should say it's one of the big
differences
when they say health care is a human
right what they're saying is
the labor of a class of people belongs
to the people yeah it's socialist
it's it's not a human right you can't
force someone to do anything so
what what's gonna happen you're gonna go
to a hospital and be like
i try i try asking my my lefty friends
this they have no answer and they just
kind of just dance around it because
they can't
if healthcare is a human right what
would happen if what would you do
if you went to a hospital the doctor
said i refuse to treat this person
do you point a gun at them and say do it
or else
that's i mean what do you do if they say
no yeah i mean you're you're in a
position where
you you can't do anything without
violating their rights
yeah you know you can't force someone to
do something without violating their
their innate right to say i don't want
to you know
maybe the npc people just uh
have no individuality well and so they
don't they don't care to lose it
right when it comes to rights like we i
think people should have a human right
to the internet right now because it's
technologically simple
so if medicine was simple if it didn't
take you you or any other person if i
could walk into like a dna
replicator that would just heal my body
back to full then everyone should have a
right to that i think
well you're so good i was going to say
yeah yeah in the world where we have
post-scarcity technology and everyone
can be healed
totally different arguments right so
like a right to the internet now because
electricity is so free and cheap for the
most part that
we can gain new rights human basic human
rights i think i i don't know i think
that i disagree
and i think the reason i disagree is
because to have a right to the internet
would imply that you have a right to a
connection to the internet
that has to be built by people
maintained by people maintained by
people electricity you have
yeah there's a lot of things that go
into it you have the right to
access the internet yes yes so you have
you have the right to access
health care you have the right to access
a gun to defend your life the the right
to defend your life
is innate regardless of whether or not
you have a gun i'll tell you why
if i attack if i jump across here and i
attack you right you have the right to
defend yourself
empty-handed right yeah um if you had a
gun
on you and i was threatening your life
you have the right to use that gun
to defend your life it's the defending
of your life that's the right
and then the protection afforded you
in the second amendment is that the
government cannot
prevent you from from using
a tool or whatever tool you
find best will help you defend your life
so
the second amendment covers knives it
covers nunchucks it covers
bows and arrows it covers anything that
that's a weapon that's like covers
warships it does cover warships
i love this argument from the left that
they're like they
they expect you to have a musket i don't
i don't know if you've ever seen this
commercial
where an angry guy storms into an office
and then he aims the musket and fires
and then starts you know he puts the
gunpowder in and starts stuffing
everyone runs away
and they're like this is what the
founding fathers were talking about and
i'm like dude
corsairs and privateers were a whole
part of this thing for hundreds of years
you had dudes who privately owned
warships that would sink
government vessels second amendment
covers everything dude
i want tanks yes me too well tanks are
legal
things are legal and i remember there
was some guy who tweeted
you can't own a tank dude and then it
was actually this this it was a lefty
like a progressive who was like actually
and they wrote a story about a dude who
owned a tank and was firing a full auto
50 cal into it into a lake on his
property
and the police got a call because they
go the cops show up pull up and they see
this kind of tank
into his lake and then he stops and he
takes his headphones off or whatever and
he waves and they're like
it's your property and he goes yeah and
they're like carry on sir that was it
like
it's not legal what are you blowing all
that money for
come on i'll tell you what though i got
good news for you
now that the the progressives have
shifted the the
argument from negative to positive
healthcare being a human right
if we have a right to access something
if our rights are positive
then the government is obligated to give
us all guns i know you know you'd think
if only it worked out you get a voucher
and then you go to the
department of gun services and you you
show your voucher and it's good for one
long gun
we all know how crappy would be i know
oh yeah that's a good point
i don't know a lot about guns but it
would probably jam all the time i can
talk later yeah
i know a lot about guns what's a really
crappy gun you think the government
would give if they had to give guns uh
well i mean if they had to give guns
they've got ars now or m16s now
so um i guess they would give those but
they probably wouldn't be
in proper working order it would be a it
would probably be
a government manufactured low quality
low caliber
high points what is that it's garbage
and i'm sure there are people watching
now that are
like yeah that's what the government
gives the high point high point is it's
uh
but if it's the only gun you've got it's
the only gun you've got man i'm not
trying to do it's a guy but yeah it is a
gun
yeah i mean man since uh the riots
you've got i don't know did you hear
about this historical exodus of police
in seattle
that's something that i think that that
i was kind of hoping that we would talk
about is
i think that there's going to be a lot
there's going to be a significant
increase in violence in
in cities all over the country because
cops ain't having it
they're just like man you do you yeah
you know
yeah i i i and i'm i'm afraid for what
that means for your average person
that just wants to go and live their
life but like
you know i i'm not in any rush to see
new york city look like it did in taxi
driver
you know that were in june in june
just a couple months ago yeah it's true
it's true
i know people that live in new york that
uh you know they're like man
you know there's there's some some wild
stuff going on
and you know gunshots just hanging out
in brooklyn and
and stuff and it's it's worse than
people know i've been i've been hearing
some stories man
i i'm sure that they're not publicized
on big media you know
check it out if if if you're walking on
the street in new york and someone
punches in the face that news
if it's rick moran if it's rick moran
for regular people it's not
and i was just talking to some guys and
they were saying like in minneapolis
and it was crazy this guy was like we
were talking about crime and defending
the police and then he just stops and
goes oh hey did you hear so and so god
got punched in the face and like what
what just randomly punched in the face i
was like wait wait you know somebody's
walking on street someone punch him in
the face
yeah and that's not normal no it never
happens
it's not news new york time's not going
to come out and be like another woman
was punched but apparently attacks like
this
are happening in a bunch of these cities
and the cops don't care anymore
so in seattle i think the number is 118
have quit the force and and probably
dozens more are
doing blue flu right where they call in
sick all the time and they're using
their pay their leave
until they can get close to retirement
so this is from uh
ktth 770 up in i think it's in seattle i
forgot the guy's name jason rantz maybe
yeah i love him yeah
and he was saying that they they looked
into it they checked the numbers
and this is a historical exodus from the
police department like this number is
ridiculously huge
and there and response times for 911
calls is up to nine minutes
nine minutes what so so here's here's
what i was thinking
if i'm gonna be in a city where they
tell me i can't have a gun i can't
protect myself
and they're telling me the 911 is not
gonna be able to get to me for ten nine
ten minutes
yeah what's that saying when seconds
matter the cops are minutes away
yeah yeah so i left the city yeah
i mean i so i lived in new york and i
lived on that street where that black
supremacist killed those two cops if you
remember that story
and that was when i was like oh man i
probably shouldn't live here i went down
to miami for a little bit when i came
back i went to the jersey side
now someone planted bombs in jersey city
and in manhattan and that was crazy and
i was like i really want to get away
like i can see the tensions escalating
so i moved to south jersey
now i'm in the suburbs on the other side
of the river from philly which is not
that big and i'm like everything's fine
and then the riots happened in june and
the helicopters were
you could see him yeah and the sirens
too and i was like i'm in the middle of
nowhere
what is this so now you thought you were
in the middle of nowhere now relative
for me growing up in chicago in the city
people like whenever i say i'm from
chicago they're like oh which suburb and
i'm like
i was in the city yeah yeah so now like
the suburbs are the middle of nowhere
no not good enough they cross the bridge
and i'm like why
they were purposefully coming they
actually came to my sleepy suburb
town and i got an email notification
from people where like that next door
app and they were like
why are they coming here that was when
you were that's when carl came over and
you guys were doing that uh
no no no no no all this yeah that was
last year okay last year i'm talking
about the riots now
like people were like yo why are they
coming to our suburb for this
yeah like why same thing happened in
chicago but yeah the the event i did
with uh with with sargon that was in
southern jersey so it was in southern
jersey it was in pittman and this is
this is hilarious because these antifa
people came from far away from like
brunswick or whatever from
you know half an hour north of i lived
there like i literally
lived about five miles from the theater
and they were like we don't want these
people coming to our town and i was like
dude you came to my town i live here i'm
putting an event with my friends
and that that was where they called
daryl davis a white supremacist yeah
god what a ridiculous what a
i ridiculous not believe it like there
is
there are very few people that you can
think of that have
actually put more work into
changing hearts and minds than daryl
davis and
some dumb probably 20 year old
kid college kid who thinks who who
probably thinks you know
mao was all right and then he's like you
know i'm
i'm a marxist leninist and uh you know
daryl davis is a white supremacist and
it's like
and he made a post about it yeah so so i
think most people know who daryl is but
he's de-radicalized like 200 plus
klansmen
and he's a black jazz musician he's a
he's an amazing person
and he said he just wanted to talk to
him to understand them and that
proximity and that friendship actually
changed their minds and changed their
world view
is there not a better refutation of the
idea that you should punch nazis than
daryl davis
you're not going to convince like when
you nobody punched the nazi
out of spencer that day he got sucker
punched they didn't punch the racism out
of him didn't work
didn't work at all that that man is just
as racist as he was before he got
punched with different tactics
yeah yeah yeah but daryl davis sits down
and talks to people
and klansmen that you know will actually
wear that
dumb ass outfit in public
and he can talk them out of it i just
mess up by swearing is that
you know but i mean like seriously like
daryl davis talks people
out of being klansmen and befriends
people that were
racist racists his stories are amazing
it's amazing
like that one story he has where he met
this uh this this clansmen
and a lot of these guys just never
actually met or interacted with a black
person
and when he was talking to this guy the
guy was a big fan of rock and roll and
him being this musician
had access he's like i can get i can
show you this famous car
and this this this this racist guy this
white supremacist is like
you can actually get me i can you can
sit in the car he's like
and then he went there and i i'm
probably i'm probably ruining daryl's
story but it was like
it was it was so like man i was well
enough when i heard it he brings this
racist guy
he sees this car from this rock legend
he's always dreamed of and he gave daryl
a hug
and he was like that that that shattered
that racism in a moment
he was like this guy is like one of the
coolest nicest guys ever to help me do
this
man i love i love the stories he what so
we did that event
and he told these stories and it was
just like he got a standing ovation
good for him because but it wasn't this
profound thing where he did this great
deal of work where he's like writing
down trying to figure out what to say
he just sat down and said what up yeah
and we talked he's just a person you
know
and then it was it was simply the act of
trying to communicate with them
that allowed them to understand their
racist views didn't make sense yeah
my favorite story was that he said well
that was my favorite story but in one of
his stories he said that
he was hanging out with this clan member
who stayed a clan member until one day
he was at a meeting he's this this clan
guy told him was in a meeting and he
heard them saying all these things about
black people and then he stopped and
thought
that's not like daryl at all i don't
this doesn't make sense anymore
and then he gave his robes to daryl that
dude is amazing those stories are so
cool
is it true that he collected a bunch of
robes yes that is the coolest
that is the coolest like scalping racist
just taking
here seriously that's what it is it's
just it's take just scalping racist and
taking that away from them and being
like
they that's the coolest they gave him
their robes
yeah and then at this at his events he
brings them and he shows them off
and he says people often tell him to
burn him and destroy them and he was
like no
no this represents someone leaving and
the victory and it's like
it's it's like capturing the flag almost
like yeah yeah
totally captured absolutely yeah but but
it's
you know i think it's important to show
that like his approach
in receiving these wasn't in any way
adversarial yeah he wasn't like haha now
i've got your rope he was like wow i
can't believe you've given this to me
that's that's that's that's tremendous
that's
that's an amazing thing to do yeah
antifa's not convincing anyone there
no they're not the kids that are out
there that are getting into fights and
stuff and
and you know uh taking advantage if you
look at the
this is one thing that i that i saw you
look at the the mug shots of the people
in portland and douglas murray said
recently on a
uh on a podcast he said if you look at
those
mug shots those are people
in chaos yep you can look at them and
see
they're probably some type of mentally
ill
you know um some kind of something like
that you know and
and so you've got people that are taking
advantage of of them and getting
people that are probably some you know
probably mentally ill
to go out and behave violently and act
out
and they're being you know egged on by
people that probably aren't mentally ill
yup
and they're just using them that's
exactly what i've been saying you know
like the joker
yeah in the in the dark knight the the
paranoid schizophrenic
two-face is interrogating him batman's
like he joker preys upon
paranoids gets a front x like this that
is that is so interesting and
compassionate what douglas is saying
there
because i think that is consistent i was
looking at and i even asked some of my
twitter followers i was like
is being this weird looking a cause or
an effect of being in antifa
and i think it is just a sign of chaos i
think the crazy hair color i think the
crazy eyes
yeah i think they are a sign of chaos
and i think it's it's good and it's
right a little bit compassionate free
radicals
yeah yeah sure they don't really fit
into any kind of culture they're just
kind of out there
doing whatever so i'll tell you what's
one of the things that scares me is uh
there's something i call the scaling
problem so the way i explain it is
if uh apple releases a hundred iphones
to a bunch of celebrities and one
percent of them breaks
one celebrity goes my phone broke and
everyone goes oh that sucks
if they release a hundred million
iphones to the public and one percent
breaks
you got a hundred you got you got one
million posts on twitter
of broken phones trending nationwide and
they're like
what is going on with these phones what
but it's the same failure rate
yep so what happens when you have you
know let's say
out of a society you you end up with
like point
zero zero zero one percent of people or
for every every hundred thousand people
you get one
violent lunatic as our population grows
and expands
you start seeing more and more violent
lunatics then they become groups of
violent lunatics
then they start going around smashing
and destroying things yeah so what do
you do
especially when you have a like a
an exploitation of these people for
political gain so then you end up with
establishment protection
so you have these people who are going
around clearly unwell you know they're
not all they're not all with it
and when they smash things up they're
called peaceful protesters
uh what i don't understand is it's
helping trump
the riots are good for trump it's bad
for biden
they try to hide it it's bad for biden
but it's less bad for trump i don't
think it's good for anybody
no i think it's good for trump no i mean
they're terrible for everybody right now
seems like it politically it's good for
trump yeah like of course riots are bad
for everybody
but i'm saying in in terms of politics i
know people who were
hardcore democrat and then the riots hit
their town
and they became republicans not even
republicans they still hate republicans
but they're like but we need trump to do
something about this
yesterday biden tweeted that or someone
tweeted with his account
that trump is the reason for the economy
falling apart
that is the most ridiculous grasping at
straws
that's amazing they're all these
comments they're like there's a pandemic
dude
yeah bro bro remember yeah it's pandemic
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you